>>When I think of the funding
situation in the state of Arizona,
it's kind of like the Titanic.
We are 49th in the country, and here
as the little Vail School District,
we are the lowest in
all of Pima County.
We used to have $60,000 as a school
to spend on instructional aids.
We have now about 10,000
to spend as a school.
And so we've had to become
creative on how we spend those funds
and what we use those funds for.
>>Nancy: Our district really handles
the budget differently than a lot
of schools do, so they
are able to stretch this.
With the minimal things that
we're getting, one of the things
that we've done is try and
cut down our copy budget.
Each of us has a blog, a website
that we post our things,
like our newsletters on.
>>The blog also helps with
students who lose things a lot,
because instead of me going
and reprinting the papers,
I can just tell them, 'Well,
you need to go to the blog.'
You wanna help him out, Max?
>>Katie: I go to Home Depot
and I'll buy this big sheet
of this special board and Home
Depot will cut that for me
and for $90, I have 600 slate boards.
And so instead of having
to use a piece
of paper every time a
teacher asks a student
to write something, we
use our slate boards.
>>Student: 024 secure 8 is composite.
>>Teacher: At the end
of the number, right?
So erase your white boards for
divisibility rule for two--
>>Matthew: They're great, because
you get away from raising your hand,
giving a thumbs up, thumbs down.
You get a quick response and you get
instant feedback from your students.
>>Teacher: They're going to
do it themselves then hold
onto it the whole year, right?
[Nancy:] That's what I want to do.
>>Katie: We put worksheets or
different activities inside
of a pocket sheet protector
and students will write
with a dry erase marker
on that pocket sheet.
We erase it when the next
group comes and use it again.
>>Crystal: At my reading
stations, I copy all the paper
that children are not supposed
to write on in colored paper,
so that they know that
this is something
that they're not gonna
go put their name on.
They're not gonna go mark up.
This is something that
I'll keep year after year.
>>Katie: We created what
we call Beyond Textbooks,
and it's an internet application
where teachers can take
those wonderful ideas
and they can post it on a Wiki page.
Our last textbook order at
Mesquite was probably six years ago.
So we've got the ship,
funding-wise, that's going down,
but miraculously, our
achievement's not.
Our achievement is the highest
in the state of Arizona.